hey everyone happy new year I'm shooting
this on New Year's Eve and I thought I
would do like a get ready with me for
2018 video where I put on my makeup and
I talked to you about my year 2017 and
my goals and hopes and dreams and
aspirations for 2018 so it's a tiny
video and I hope you like it so keep on
watching okay I'm gonna start off with
some concealer I'm not gonna say which
type of product I'm using because all of
them are just kind of old and gross
so um yesterday I wrote down all of the
things that happened to me in 2017
everything from you know actual events
that have happened to like feelings that
I've had it kind of turned out to be a
pretty interesting list like I wrote a
whole lot of it down like that's all the
stuff that happened to me and it's a lot
if I had to sum up my 2017 into like a
phrase I would say it was like finding
my purpose and my passion I've always
known that like my purpose in life and
what I want to do with my life was to
like help other people through what I
was doing the how it was a very
difficult question to answer and finding
your passion in life is also doesn't
come that easy all the time I know the
things that make me happy you know
figuring out from there like how do I
translate that into like a passion or
like an actual thing that I can create
was the thing I think a thing that I
figured out and 1:17 it was the first
time that I kind of like paved my own
path a person who's pretty like
risk-averse I would say I I typically
tend to take like the safer path or like
the path well-traveled and I think
that's also why I wanted to software
engineering in a lot of ways because all
my life my parents were like hey and we
go whatever you do just make sure that
you are able to financially sustain
yourself know that I have this like
position that I'm in that you know I can
afford to do all like things that I want
to do now what is it that I really want
to do
and I think yeah 2017 was like a year
that I actually like thought about that
really hard and realized what it is that
I could try to do at least although I'm
not going to like pewter around the bush
and say that wasn't a tough year I think
for like news and politics and
everything that's going on in the world
it was probably like the hardest year
I've never been so attuned to like you
know world news before um luckily like I
was fortunate and that I didn't get
affected by any of this like super
directly you know every time there was
news about like North Korea doing like a
bomb thing or something I was like okay
like that's terrifying cuz my parents
are in Tokyo and that's super close yeah
pretty interesting year I wonder what
like history books and stuff are gonna
say about the year 2017 because I would
say it was a pretty like different year
yeah being an adult means that you know
you're paying attention to this stuff
now so yeah um this year I started on my
YouTube channel and I posted nine videos
I'm pretty proud of that but I also what
am I like resolutions for 2018 is to
post a lot more I'm hoping to post like
I think I'm gonna say twice a month
right now getting a video out once a
week is tough but I do one of my other
resolutions for 2018 is to become a
better writer and so I do want to write
a script maybe every week or just
anything really every week writing is
not a skill that I like inherently
worked on very much growing up because I
was like I'm gonna need sciences I don't
need to learn how to write but turns out
being really well-written and
articulating your thoughts well is a
really important skill to have in all
different careers like especially as I'm
getting into more kind of like a senior
type of role at my job a lot of my job
is like communicating to other people
what I'm doing or what the team is doing
or the technical decisions that we've
made and doing that well is super
important and doing that in such a way
that other people will understand so
I really want to like have 2018 be a
year of consistency and like
meaningfulness is all the things that I
figured out about myself in 2017 the
purpose and the passion that I found in
2017 I want to make sure that I follow
through with that in 2018 I think I have
a little bit of a follow-through problem
and so doing that I think will help and
something that I want to work on
instead of writing goals I said you know
by the end of 2018 I want to be I don't
want to be afraid to be friends with
people that I admire I do a thing like
putting people on to like a pedestal
when I really like them and so I think
of them as kind of like a god I'm just
like wow you're so incredible like I
know who you are and you know who I am
and that alone is enough they say
surround yourself with people who make
you better and that you admire but if I
keep putting people on a pedestal I
can't do that because then I'm always
just gonna be like no like don't hang
out with me I'm not worthy like ah so I
think part of it is like imposter
syndrome but I don't want to do that
anymore and I actually do want to get to
know the people that I really admire and
hang out with them because I feel like
it's a missed opportunity on otherwise
you know okay I'm about to put on my
eyeliner but this might be hard because
usually use two hands and I needed my
other hand to hold up my mirror okay
I'm gonna have to do this off camera
because this is not working okay I'm
back cool and I totally forgot what
we're talking about so I'm just gonna
start somewhere
oh that's right I was talking about not
being afraid to be friends with people
that I admire I get invited to coffee
dates a lot and stuff but I've never
really invited other people to coffee
dates so I'm gonna do that more because
I want to have more like meaningful
connections with people this next year
and doing that with people that I really
admire I think would be really cool my
other thing is like have more meaningful
interactions so that means less social
media and more like copy dates more
phone calls but
you know I think a big part of this is
just like learning to let go and not
think so much about what other people
are gonna think of me because that's
something that I am like so prone to I
think so hard about what other people
think of me and I need to not do that so
much because life is short and if I'm
constantly worried about what other
people will think that I'm never gonna
get anything done and 2018 is gonna be
year where I get done so I have to be
better about that things in 2018 that I
am very excited to do that are going to
happen is that I'm getting married in
August of 2018 so I'm very very excited
for that I've been planning my wedding
for a couple months now and things are
shaping up pretty well I've never been
the type of person to like have a dream
wedding or like have thought about what
my wedding was gonna look like when I
was 12 like this I didn't think about
that at all you know all of this like
wedding stuff is like brand-new to me I
don't know anything so it's a lot of
like learning and figuring out what I
want as well as like balancing the cost
and making sure that everyone else gets
their say
so it's kind of like a mini project if
you will so it's another like I guess if
you can call it a side project a side
project
what else's happen to me in 2018 you
know putting on mascara while doing
anything else is like impossible all
done okay so what else is happening 2018
I just bought my tickets to go to Japan
in April in I'm very excited for that
we're going for 10 days and I'm gonna go
visit my parents and my grandparents
Scott and I are both going and in April
hopefully the cherry blossoms are super
beautiful because I haven't seen the
cherry blossoms in years and it's like
astounding so I'm really excited for
that I'm going to VidCon in June and
that'll be great because last year has
been kind of had a lot of fun and that's
why I decided to start my YouTube
channel to begin with and so going this
year as like a creator and you know
learning a lot about youtubing and
meeting a lot of other youtubers who are
starting I think
is gonna be really fun um I think that's
all I have planned for 2018 right now
I'm trying not to travel so much in 2018
content even teen was a lot of travel it
felt like from May to maybe like
November all I did was travel in order
for me to stay consistent with things
that I want to do for 2018 I basically
like me to be home I'm not very good at
doing things on the go because I'm like
I want to enjoy the moment that I'm in
and so being at home I think will help a
lot other than that I think 2018 is
gonna be a great year and I'm really
excited for all the things that are
gonna come I love this blush because
I've got a little bit of shimmer in it
so axe is kind of like highlighter slash
blush which is great I remember you can
see the shininess of my cheeks but it's
great I love it
hey I actually haven't put on makeup in
a really long time my face has been
basically makeup lists for like the last
week cuz I took a week and a half off
and he had a little bit of a break and
it was great I slept so much and I
finally like took care of myself and my
mind my body and so I just didn't put on
makeup because I couldn't be bothered to
and so that's that's it this is my final
look yeah I hope you all had a great
2017 that I know I did it was every year
I say this but it was like the best year
yet and I'm really looking forward to
2018 and I hope you are too so let me
know what your resolutions are for 2018
and maybe we can be accountability
buddies so let me know in the comments
down below and I will see you next year
bye
[Music]